a proper western i mean we see tom hanks
gun totin which we rarely see
well i don't have i don't wear one i am
given one later on so it's not like you
know i'm not doing the root and tubing
kind of
but i
i i i ride a horse and um i drive a
wagon and i've discovered so i'm not a
i'm not a writer per se but i did learn
i i had a fabulous
got to know a fabulous horp named wimpy
who was my horse wimpy was my horse
and uh
i don't know if anybody here is has
ridden a lot or made a western emily has
a couple of westerns under her belt as i
recall emily my darling how are you
wonderful to see me
do you know i'm about to do a western
like next january i'm doing a six-part
western and we were just discussing how
allergic i am to horses and i do every
scene with a horse you know i'm gonna be
antihistamined up to my eyeball
do you have to
kiss the horse
isn't that what happens in westerns to
make out with your horse you you develop
an affection for those beasts
you and will become
which you sort of have to do because i
have a feeling that horses honestly they
would much rather live in a world
without human beings climbing on top
and they know the moment you climb on
their back that you're terrible at
riding like i mean i've been learning
right now i'm i'm in london now
rehearsing for it and i go riding three
times a week and every time they give me
a different horse to see you know how
you fare oh with one that's more
sprightly or one that's less of a
ferrari and i got on one the other day
called rusty oh my god they almost took
off with me it was terrifying
i couldn't walk the next day rusty did
me in
rusty did her in rusty
oh
wow
is that the name of the film
[Applause]
i think in case this gets awkward later
i think i should bring this up now yes
that uh john bishop you do have a
connection to tom cruise uh
yes yes yes uh yeah we do have a
connection because we were both i was on
uh top gear
shortly after tom was on top gear this
is the star in a reasonably nice car the
star in the reasonably priced car and
you did very well top i did all right
yeah yeah you're top of the leaderboard
how did you do john yeah
well here's the leaderboard
john bishop yeah beat you two seconds
[Applause]
and then and then ripper clinch his
fourth wasn't he rupert grint yes yes
i'm a wizard i even beat a wizard
tell me that you didn't just beat us you
crushed us that's 142.8 that's
that's a good uh full second and a half
almost i know and the thing is like you
can drive cars and you're interested
i've got zero interest in cars
you chose the wrong profession
tell me about it i came away from that
thing and i've i should be an f1 because
all it was to me though was somebody
give me a car yeah and said it doesn't
matter if you crash it
this is great this is like being 17
again on my dad's
[Laughter]
don't make it sound stupid and pointless
yes please it's very serious
it's actually not just like there's
turns like you gotta make right turns
and left turns
because
one of the things you're not going to
miss is the terrible toll in a second on
your bottom i don't know
i'm sitting here in the brace
no it's all great
no time to die no time to die what did
you break in no time to die my ankle
i mean you just
like literally walking down a plank i
mean not even i wasn't running wasn't
even doing anything action-based i just
walked down slipped and fell over it was
so stupid and over the films what so
what's the worst injury you've had
probably my knee which was on spectre
which was um that was dave bautista god
bless him who is
a professional wrestler
we were doing this scene as a fight
sequence on um
a train in inspector and we we learned
this for weeks and weeks and weeks and
weeks and weeks and and you know you
kind of you basically spend a week
shooting it and the whole thing is there
and dave was being really great with me
but he's a big big guy and i forget how
big he is and he was sort of throwing me
against this wall he's being gentle
because you know so he should it's
pretend
um and
i just said dave dave mate go on it's
all right come on you can chuck me a bit
don't worry about it i'm fine
so we did
i ended up on the wall but my knee was
sort of over here somewhere
and i said it went oh god like and went
and i knew and it's horrible because if
anybody's had an injury they kind of you
know kind of that kind of injury you
just know in your head that something's
really wrong and
god bless him i i was out and then we
went back and we reformed it i had to
film it with a brace on and we kind of
and it was very it was a struggle to do
it but i got i broke his nose oh
what
um don't mess with the crate
i didn't do it literally clearly it was
like it was a mistake and it was so like
i mean like i said he's a big guy he's a
professional wrestler you really
wouldn't mess with him and i threw this
punch i hit him on the nose and i heard
this crack and i went oh god and ran
away
i thought he was gonna come up
and he was so sweet and he literally did
something like this he went away that's
fine no
i mean he's a lot tougher than i am i'll
give you that tom daley i like this part
of the year after olympics because we
get olympians with medals and uh tom
delhi now is a gold medal yeah
[Applause]
now
it
it looks a bit like christmas morning on
the table beside you
what have we got tom oh we've got a
whole selection they've got a whole
catalogue of things first up i feel like
i'm on like a tv like sales show right
qvc yeah so we've got my knitted pouch
which then has inside
[Applause]
that's fun so there we are
that's very good i've just chugged off
the floor
be all right yeah you know what i'll
nick them yeah
some crocheted
swim trunks
now can i just stop you there i'm not
gonna put them on no but they also
they're not i mean because if you get
them wet they are gonna retain a lot of
water a lot
a lot of moisture yeah it's not it's not
something i would probably wear
it was actually something one of my
first projects that i made on a training
camp and i dare and get them wet because
if you get wool wet i mean you know how
it goes if you try and wash any knitwear
yes it's like you know they they shrink
quite considerably so you wouldn't
really want to wear them into the pool
no and your talks can't get any smaller
tom so uh i don't want anything falling
out
you've been through is that the famous
cardigan this is the cardigan that i
made at the olympics
to commemorate my
olympics
just got like ignore the inside because
the inside's the wrong side but yeah
it's got like a bit of a it was a team
gb jumper for me to remember my tokyo
olympics looks like you were in tokyo
for about six months
there was a lot of spare time to put it
that way
no one was more surprised than me that
she said yes
can i tell you something can i tell you
what was happening in that obviously
that's the edited scene but i'll tell
you
we had a we had someone laurie the first
ad was operating a fart machine just off
to the right and that isn't a real
bathroom that was a bedroom in the house
because the the bathroom wasn't small
enough wasn't big enough sorry so
we took a bedroom and we converted it so
it's a prop toilet prop sink
etcetera and um
so we had laurie uh operating a fart
machine just off to my right here so
that we could have the occasional subtle
little
break of wind from heleno while she's
holding me hostage in the toilet and i
was doing the scene
and then
he was getting so trigger-happy it was
ridiculous i was trying to do lines and
there was
it was bloody ridiculous so in the end i
had to stop acting i looked over at him
and he wasn't pressing the button
and i went
and i looked behind me
it was princess margaret going off
like a tugboat behind me
genuinely farting
and i only i'd only just got over the
shock that helena bonham cartridge said
yes to my thing and then she was farting
within feet of me
and i went helena and she found it so
funny she found her own farting which
was magnificent i might say
she found her own farting so funny she
then worked herself
and had to leave the set and while she
was leaving the set she was shouting at
the top of her voice it's natural
[Applause]
in ghostbusters there are lots of very
impressive special effects and visual
effects but you yourself using a camera
phone
you can create a visual effect
i can yes where it appears that people
are seeing something they're not that's
right okay can you demonstrate it
sure good
[Applause]
um can i just say you are all going to
be trying this
yeah this is uh
i can i tried
what do i need to do just sit there okay
this should be fine
all right
i think we can
do you know what he's doing yes i do
you will in a minute
it should be synced to uh yeah i think
it's sync now so here's the picture that
you just took
so
[Applause]
it does look like a
i'm bum
much really confused
what what happened
oh yes do miriam there we go are you
doing it with your fingers
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what is that
it does look like a bottom yes
i happen to have really sausage looking
fingers
that make a really nice tush
and you can frame you
you can frame it frame the camera so it
looks like you're just just i just got
to know how you discovered this unique i
know that's what i want of yours
there's an even more sophisticated
version
yeah okay
there's there's you can do i mean
well let's see if i can
i don't know if it's if sophisticated is
the right word but
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
very good
talking of the voice how long
before you developed the voice or did
you find it pretty quickly uh i started
in the voice six months before we
started filming and then i stayed in it
while we were filming of course which
was really super fun for adam
[Music]
i made him deal with that every
day
but you know i actually still doing it
but it actually for me i don't know for
what it's worth ridley shoots fast and
he's got four cameras going
once at any given time if not more so i
thought it was harder to go in and out
of character i thought it was actually
easier to stay in character on set so i
i wish not to sensationalize this thing
but i do wish to uh express gratitude to
my fellow actor that i was on stage with
every day you know no okay
this is nearly it but we go just time
for a quick visit to the big red chair
now alan is all set there he is he's
ready he's ready
okay let's find out uh who's going to be
trying to keep you in that chair who's
up first hello
hi what's your name
francesca francesca and where are you
francesca
i'm in north finchley in london
lovely i don't like the colour of your
curtains
they're not mine i'm in a house
right back at you
they're not my choice
what do you do in north finchley
uh i'm an actor and i also work in a
local pub
okay so nothing um
unemployed
i've been there it gets better
thank you please put me on bridget and
i'd love to be on it yeah yeah yeah
all right off you go with this story and
remember you're trying to keep alan in
that chair okay good luck everyone off
you go okay so a few years ago i was
working in sheffield in a theatre
and we have this barn restaurant where
the audience and cast would come before
and after a show
one night this famous person had been to
see the show and came into the bar
afterwards where i served them
and i was making their drinks i think it
was like two gin and tonics and as i was
making their drinks these two cast
members came over and started asking for
their photos and that kind of thing so i
put the drinks on the bar they turn
around pick up their drinks and then
walk over to their table without paying
now you're probably wondering who this
famous person is it was graeme norton
i knew it was gonna be me
i never pay for drinks
how dare she ask me for money
i'm supporting live
it theater an accident
i'm so sorry alan
can you warn me next time you've been
tight
[Music]
you